o lado pessoal de quem fala é o dark
surgiu muito bem vindo já mais de um
vídeo e um estrado de que faz sete
prédios 3d no modo ultra e não só
consegui também não é para largar pega o
vasco é campeão em fullscreen aumentem o
volume vamos por cada coisa juntos
porque isso vai ser em modo ultra outra
qualquer pessoa bastante aqui no gol
night at freddy's 3d
vamos lá então buscar um modo cultura
confronte duper love de molho em julho e
ouviu um barulho qualquer lado que é
isto de fato já serão todos lá ô ô ô ô
[Música]
lá qualquer fala agora vamos conseguir
passar esta noite ainda só tentei uma
vez não eu acho que não vou ficar aqui
algumas vezes mas vamos lá tentar passar
esta noite eu consegui ficar aqui até à
uma da manhã foi isso agora é voltar e
de 10 na porta porque quando começar a
ouvir os passos da fox e é essencial
para fechar a porta e ouvir qualquer
coisa eu não conseguia perceber de onde
é que vem o por lei sob um sol y é um
dislate por celular e telefone
com os dois os dois juntos alá deus
querem comer um culto anda agora não
teria custo de negociar e de ouvir uma
nuvem a minha frente eu tô só tem uma
porta e ela tava bater na porta
filha de mãe e filha da mãe conseguiu
esquivar de foxy já possui e já está
fechada e que possa não
mas o que fiquei confuso agora eu vi
posso desfilando e ouvir posse de
explosivos mas acho que não era fox rock
a brecha não não eu já tô de cara mal do
contexto poderia eu tô com 3 por cento
teria tudo escuro porque quando o piloto
deu através da arte porque muitos dos
jogos art
fred morrer o que é dito agora já sei
que neste início vou ter que aguentar
aqui um pouco sem sentir nenhuma luz nem
ver as portas porque eu sei que eu só
vou torcer a partir da uma da manhã e
explorar sem mexer em nada porque temos
que poupar a bateria o máximo que eu não
tomo xerém nada e ela está em 97% ela
acaba muito rápido a cair amanhã à noite
quando ficar uma da manhã e começa a ver
as luzes e e e ficar atento aos ruídos
não é porque eu falo aqui uma da manhã
uma da manhã que estamos carentes
eu acho que aguentar essa coisa até o
fim
pode perguntar até as chances da manhã
para depois vamos pagar em duas séries
bauru ataque em peshawar porta fica
proibida a festa também pronto ética
quando aparece aqui a luz fica toda a
possuída parece um bicho de dentro da
outra vez que os dois detidos flávio
boninho bonita aqui também é posto não
só foi embora aí abre tudo isso na fox
ordenou por cima do inter atendeu a fox
puxa tudo o que eu acho que esta já
pobre né
eu acho que sim
o frio apanhando agora tá tranquilo o
pessoal 3 36% e baterias são três também
estamos aguentar muito banda larga e
asfaltado tem placa lah 14 da minha boa
faltam duas horas nem 24 horas deixe
deste ao vosso laico pessoal vamos
apoiar este modo um traço do imac passar
esta noite deixou o vosso apoio o
canditato tranquilo agora
eu sempre vi a cara é preciso um barulho
não dá não dá não dá não dá não dá bomba
ó aí vamos usar a mesma técnica quer
ficar aqui até à uma da manhã sem fazer
pão da vida e depois de i condição de
usar as portas de estilos e vou tentar
agora usará menos duas portas e outras
vão usar menos o caráter pois toca de
tudo a itália embora e agora vou esperar
que venha pra porta exatamente novo
jackson deixa para depois dizer que não
vai ter que ela estava possuída
ele está tranqüilo chamei ela avançou
avançou criança na porta e não vou abrir
aquela porta deixando está aqui
aqui o freetalk agora vos trago freire
por isso aqui à frente deixamos só
existiam embora
peluso isso agora esta foi só porque
lançou o filho da mãe rita leone e que a
ética vamos para a frente isso agora
faixa que ela ainda não faz nada
o homem jacko jacko ok é poupar bateria
até à última
isso vai fechar muito bem embora não
está aqui alguma coisa tu não tá nem
televisão fox e olha o nem cerca de meia
hora
agora temos que esperar com um passo à
frente exatamente já passou aqui alguma
coisa solta às quatro da manhã com 40% e
patrimóvel cinco da manhã
bur por cinco da manhã às cinco da manhã
pessoal vamos conseguir passar essa
calma o que não sei se vai conseguir
entrar aqui a mesma mas temos 10%
poderia passar esta noite que vai
acontecer é só isto
ok ok conseguir passar é um fogo de
artifício de estupro
mas ecclestone deu um xeque nos planos
verão dinheiro não terão prêmios não
deram nada é por eu ficar aqui seis
horas
então é isso só vamos ficar porque
construir espero assistir um estado que
deixou o united fred em san andrés já
sabem quanto o flick favorito porque
isso ajuda muito
aqui o canal do lado do fred em breve
isso ajuda muito final aqui do dou esse
usuário dos frangos por isso este mesmo
vosso apoio like favorito fique bem até
apróxima e agora vou tomar um banho que
o cheiro não chega a ser muito agradável
não
[Música]